well last week was not a good week to
put it lightly ending with the horrific
slaughter of 11 worshippers at a
synagogue in Pittsburgh beginning with
the mail bombs apparently sent by a
clearly insane Trump supporter and
midway through the week there was a
shooting at a Kroger in Kentucky who
carried out by a racist white man
targeting black people two were killed
in that attack so I have a few things a
few things I want to say here and and
let me first say speaking specifically
about the 11 kill at the synagogue for a
moment and I know that this is not
exactly a bold statement not exactly a
statement that requires great courage or
insight to say but it must be said all
the same that anti-semitism
is evil and incredibly stupid bigotry
towards any racial group or ethnic group
or any group at all is is religious
group is evil and stupid bigotry is an
evil stupid thing for evil stupid people
but I think especially anti-semitism
among professing Christians and this
scumbag killer claimed to be a
professing Christian he's not really a
Christian but that's what he claimed to
be and especially among professional
professing Christians it is evil and
idiotic to an extreme for I would think
a rather obvious reason which is that
Jesus Christ our Lord and Savior was a
Jew all of the Apostles were Jews Paul
was a joy drew they were all they were
all Jewish Christianity is is founded
upon Judaism in fact I've I heard
someone say once that the thing that
really kind of is strange about
Christianity I think that's one of the
things that separates it from other
religions one of their unique things
about it is that it is the only religion
in the world that agrees with are not
one other religion Christianity affirms
all of Judaism
in that it affirms the the the Old
Testament now we have the New Testament
which rests upon the pillars of the Old
Testament
we have that
channel Testament then of which you know
on that point we certainly do not agree
and that is obviously an essential point
it is the center point the centerpiece
of the Christian faith but we are in
full agreement on the Old Testament so
which which I would think is rather
significant right so how can a how can a
Christian hate hate Jews then how do you
think that conversation will go when you
stand before your Lord on judgement day
how are you going to explain to your
Jewish Lord that you hate his people an
anti-semite Christian to me seems a bit
like a like a racist white jazz musician
or something I mean how could you
possibly hate the people who founded the
thing that you've given your life to you
may as well hate yourself you do sort of
hate yourself in that case and I think
that bigotry what lies at the root of
bigotry much of the time is a kind of
self-loathing in all forms of bigotry
but particularly when it comes to any
Christian who hates Jews but with with
bigotry in general to to deny to reject
the dignity of an entire group of human
beings is to deny and reject the
inherent dignity of all human beings
which is to say that you reject your own
dignity as well now we should also
stipulate I think it's important to note
and and and to be clear that
anti-semitism obviously is a huge
problem around the world has been
throughout history has always been and
in America there are fringe whack-job
crazy but clearly dangerous groups that
that also share that anti-semitism but I
think we can say safely that
anti-semitism is not at all common among
modern American Christians not at all
common bigotry in general I would say is
not common among modern American
Christians because we understand that
Jesus condemns all forms of hatred
but when it comes to to Jewish people I
think it's true that I'm biased but I
don't I don't think anyone can really
disagree that the biggest supporters of
Jewish people and of Israel outside of
Judaism itself are Christians and
specifically evangelical Christian now
when this event was unfolding I wanted
to see what was going on of course stay
up-to-date so I could either watch cable
news or I could go online that's the
choice that we all have and that's the
ultimate lose-lose the ultimate no-win
situation but I usually go with the
Internet you know that's usually where I
go for my news and when there's
especially when there's a breaking news
thing I'm on the internet not really
watching TV because I can't stand the
theatrics of cable news in the wake of
tragedy or at any other point but the
problem with being online on social
media when something like this is
happening is that you get a view of
humanity at its absolute worst so as per
usual has to be expected if you were
online at when this was all going on you
would have seen that people were
immediately politicizing the tragedy
without any hesitation the narratives
were being formed the mud was being
flung this the sickening almost gleeful
fervor of people who believe that a mass
killing will be useful to them
politically and ideologically all of
that was on was on display and we're so
used to that display we're so used to
that spectacle that there's almost no
point in bringing it up or complaining
about it at this point it's not gonna
change it's never going to change but I
do bring it up here because I think it
speaks in some ways to the question of
why this stuff happens which is the
question that we always have why is this
happening and and these mass killings do
seem to be happening with a certain
terrible frequency it's true that the
media may exaggerate the frequency of of
mass killings for political reasons
they'll tell you that there have been
whatever 200 school shootings in a year
or some crazy number like that which
which simply is not true and there's no
reason not only is it cynical and awful
to lie about something like this but
there's there's
reason to lie about it because it is
there there are plenty of real examples
that you can use and so no matter how
frequent it is and no matter how that
stacks up compared to other points in
history we know that it's far too
frequent now and so why why is it
happening well we've already talked
about bigotry clearly bigotry plays a
big part but that's not the whole whole
story because even the average rabid
bigot probably isn't going to go and
kill anybody
you've got though you've got a a subset
of bigots and among those bigots there's
own there's a smaller subset of bigots
who are willing and who may actually go
out and do something like this because
there's there's something else there
there's there's bigotry there's hate but
there's something else there's there's
another ingredient I think that's needed
in order to make a mass killer and I
think you can see that ingredient you
can observe it by looking at the kinds
of people who excitedly exploit these
kinds of events and practically cheer
when the culprit ends up being someone
from the other side because those people
I mean it really seems like they they
are happy when this happens they are
happy when it happens if it if it's if
it's something that they can use they're
people like to that that's really what
it seems like they would never say that
they would never be explicit about it
they would never admit it but when you
listen to them when you see the way they
carry on there doesn't appear to be any
sadness there is no moment of somber
reflection or compassion it is just I'm
gonna grab this thing right after the
bodies of a second after the body said
the guard I'm going to grab it and I'm
gonna use it as a as a club to beat my
political enemies with a person who does
that I think that's a person who has a
complete lack of empathy
that is a person who is callous who is
empty who is unable to recognize it
would seem the humanity of their fellow
humans they see these kinds of events
they don't see they don't see the the
cost in human life they don't that
that's not the point to them they don't
really that doesn't register on them
they just see oh good well that here's a
here's a here's a point I can raise in
an argument I think among the
ingredients that that make a mass killer
the indifference to human life this sort
of hollow unhuman disposition this
emptiness this all is if you will the
yeast that makes the bread rise and my
point is that you find that ingredient
and this is the really terrifying truth
but you find that ingredient in the
hearts of many people of apparently
normal people of every person who goes
on Twitter seconds after the bodies hit
the ground and cheerfully uses a mass
killing to their advantage in an
argument all of those people have a bit
of this ingredient within them now do I
think that all of them are going to
become mass killers no because they need
the other ingredients right but but they
do have they are part of the way there
and I would even say a significant part
of the way there because that is the
main thing that you need to make to cook
up a mass killer the main thing more
than anything else is indifference
callousness lack of empathy emptiness
because with that ingredient you don't
even you don't necessarily even need the
hatred and bigotry there have been
plenty of mass killers who don't appear
to really it would seem they have hatred
but they don't appear to have any
special bigotries the main thing is they
are completely empty and it's easy to
it's easy I think to become like that in
this country it's easy to become at a
minimum desensitized to the loss of
human life because we hear about it so
much and it just becomes it can become
if we're not careful part of the
background noise it can become just a
thing a news cycle that you read about
and then move on but then even more than
that I think when we're we spend so much
time online it's never a surprise to me
with these mass killers that you know
you find that they they spend so much
time staring at screens so much time
online in these various internet forums
and whatever it's almost every time you
find that and that's no surprise to me
because when you spend so much time
immersed in this world in this kind of
insulated anonymous world where you're
interacting with a lot of different
people but it's very easy in those
interactions in that artificial cyber
world it's easy in those interactions to
forget that that's an actual other human
being and I think if you if you are in
that environment enough too much and you
don't keep a proper perspective
eventually you may find yourself even
when you're outside of that environment
walking around in the real real world
you still have that same desensitized
[Music]
compassionless mentality just look at
yeah we get again we get so used to it
but look at any of the horrible comments
that you see under news articles or
YouTube videos people telling other
people to kill themselves and so on and
so forth and we said
that that's normal that's just how
people are on no it's not it may be
normal for for the internet but it's not
a normal thing for people it you say
something like that to someone it
doesn't matter that you're online saying
it that's it that is a horrible horrific
evil wicked disgusting despicable thing
to say to someone and the fact that
you're saying it online makes no
difference it's it's still just as evil
but the fact that we think that well
you're online and you're saying this
thing so somehow it's not quite as bad
we'll see that's the problem and I don't
know I think people can it builds a kind
of mentality that I think can ultimately
contribute to this all right one other
thing I want to talk about switching
gears dennis prager had an interesting
column on The Daily wire yesterday he
was talking about his experience car
shopping recently and what it taught him
about about young people and he says
that that the the young salespeople that
he encountered while he was car shopping
they were they were friendly they were
very sweet but they they knew nothing
about cars he said and they didn't
appear very anxious to actually land a
sale they didn't seem very ambitious
like they didn't know he's come out cars
didn't really care about selling them
and he he pointed out that young people
Millennials tend to be less ambitious
and less knowledgeable about things and
so he was using this anecdote as a way
of illustrating that point now there's
plenty of truth in what he says and I
enjoyed his column I found it
interesting I do think for the record
that the problem is not confined to
millenials into young people I think
it's more cultural than generational
I've I'm like we all have I have also
encountered plenty of not very
knowledgeable not very ambitious not
very helpful customer service people in
my day and people in general and I would
not for a moment say that a significant
majority of them have been Millennials
I've dealt with plenty of older people
who fall into that same
I was one example it's at a restaurant a
few days ago the waiter
probably in his 40s or 50s and he was
one of the worst customer service people
I've ever come across in my entire life
he was absolutely horrible and so you
know that's not uncommon
right so and I've had plenty of customer
service interactions with people that
are about my age or younger and they're
very knowledgeable very ambitious very
energetic and all that kind of stuff so
it's you know you get it across the
board I do think a lack of ambition is a
problem among Millennials more than it's
a problem among older generation
certainly ignorant lack of knowledge I
don't think that's uniquely a millennial
problem at all all right I have I have I
have run-ins with ignorant people all
the time all the time mostly online but
also in the real world quite a bit and
plenty of them are older I find plenty
of incredible ignorance and frankly
stupidity among older people and among
younger people's I think I think again
that's kind of kind of even but lack of
ambition yeah that's that's more
uniquely a young person problem it's a
bad it is a real problem too but even
that you know that's to some extent
there's there's another side of that
coin and so on the other side you have
boomers who I think and in life have
some of them many of them have tended to
be you might say too ambitious or
ambitious in the wrong way valuing money
above all else being very materialistic
at the expense of their families and
their marriages which is why the boomer
generation has been a disaster for the
marital institution the boomer
generation has been a wrecking ball on
the marital institution divorce was
epidemic in the 80s and 90s and a lot of
that was because our parents generation
had decided that professional success
was the only thing that mattered so they
were ambitious at the office at work
about making more money they were not
necessarily ambitious about about being
good spouses and and good parents this
is a generalised comment I realize it's
not the case for all of them but if
we're going to make generalized comments
about one generation we can make them
about the others too right
my point here simply that there are
flaws in every generation and if older
generations want to convey anything to
younger people they have to begin by
admitting what they did wrong what their
flaws are and this is one of the reasons
it's telling us one of the reasons why
the Millennials have closed themselves
off and are not interested in hearing
the criticisms of baby boomers because
we can look at the baby boomer
generation and say wow what a disaster
this has been in so many ways there are
some very obvious problems in that
generation that have manifested
themselves in catastrophic ways so if
you're not going to acknowledge that and
all you're going to do is look at
younger people who by the way your own
kids are you raised this is the
generation you raised we should clarify
and you're gonna look at them and blame
them for everything well it's just how
are we supposed to take that's we can't
take it seriously we couldn't possibly
take it seriously so there has to be
some self analysis and some self
criticizing that I you just don't I
don't see that often among the older
generations and I say this as some as a
millennial I criticize Millennials all
the time I mean their Millennials
criticize them of the Millennial
Generation all the time it's we it's a
very common thing and I have spilled
much ink over the last four or five
years doing exactly that you just don't
find that as much with boomers I'm not
saying it never happens but there seems
to be less of a willingness to look
within and say wow we really screwed up
in these areas now I don't mean that as
a comment directed at Dennis Prager by
the way I think it's a brilliant guy and
I really admire him I just mean this as
a general comment but to progress point
ok I don't want to I don't want to not
gonna try to ignore it I think it's a
let's focus just on Millennials here
there's a lot of truth to what he said
no matter how prevalent these problems
may also be in other generations he's
absolutely right
that among Millennials there is not
enough passion not enough ambition not
enough knowledge not enough expertise
not enough skill but the lack of passion
and and ambition to me is one because it
I
I've got a lot of problems myself a lot
of flaws that's that's one that I
haven't struggled with as much as so
it's hard for me to even understand like
how could you be a young person and not
have goals and dreams and the
willingness to go out and grab them to
me that just seems so natural and so
when I see that in younger people I also
feel like what what in the world is
wrong with you but I think if we're
gonna talk about that let's talk about
why that might be the case what has gone
wrong that has potentially created a
jannat multiple generations now of
people who do not seem very
knowledgeable and do not seem very
ambitious well if we're gonna we're
gonna try to figure out why and I don't
mean to beat up on one of my favorite
punching bags here but you know I'm
sorry we do have to look at the
education system if you're talking
you're talking about a guy you know a
young person who's 25 years old well
this is someone who has been just
recently emerged from the education
system and has been in that system his
entire life up until this point so if
you want and if there's something wrong
with him and especially if there's
something wrong with the entire
generation of people around that age it
makes sense to look at the system that
they spent their formative years in you
probably can find the source of many of
these problems in that environment
logically so it must be said that the
education system is simply not set up to
develop skills or to give a deep base of
knowledge in any subject at all or
defined and ignite a person's passion or
anything like that
it does the opposite on every score and
it is even designed to do the opposite
it creates people this is what the
education system does it creates people
who are who are like very large
sprawling wide kiddie pools it creates a
person who you know the the typical
person coming out of the education
system is going to be like a 1 mile wide
2 inch deep kiddie pool
very broad very shallow at the end of 12
or 13 years an education system a kid
will have a tiny bit of knowledge on
many subjects he will not be competent
in any of them he will have no area of
expertise or specialty or special
interest and then he will go to college
as a kind of blank slate which is how
it's designed that's what the colleges
want right and and he'll have no idea
what he's good at no idea what he cares
about no real idea what his interests
are and he'll decide sort of randomly
then what his major is going to be and
at the end of four years five years of
college he'll be 22 23 24 years old with
still a very shallow but broad base of
knowledge no expertise no skills no
special interests and an his one area of
more in-depth knowledge his major will
be maybe an area that he doesn't even
care about because he picked it
arbitrarily and without knowing anything
about it
before he chose it now as I've shared
before when I was in school I realized
very early on that I was specially
interested in writing in history I also
realized that I was specially terrible
at math and I hated it and in with a
passion and I was in it just did not
click for me it clicked you know up
through arithmetic and the really basic
stuff it click click click once we
started getting into algebra and things
like that that's when it left me behind
and I did not have the brain for it
whereas I can remember even being in you
know in a much younger student and
looking around at some of my some of my
fellow classmates who seemed to struggle
with writing and reading and things like
that and it was hard for me like how
could you struggle at this this is how
and I would see kids who are really
brilliant in math and seem to be very
smart but then it's like they write they
were you know see how they were right
there writing at a level that was three
or four steps below where I was and
that's how people are you know
so here's the problem those there were
there were the subjects that I were that
I was really interested in and I really
cared about and I was good at in in an
education system that's effective and in
an education system that is set on
creating the kind of people that Dennis
Prager Wan's and that I want and that
most of us want in that kind of system I
would have been able to double or triple
up on on the subjects that I really
cared about dive into them explore my
interests in those areas develop those
skills learn those subjects and at the
end of my time in school I would have a
deep base of knowledge a deep reservoir
of knowledge on a few subjects and I
would then have the beginnings of a
skill and a vocation and a calling right
most people unless you're Leonardo da
Vinci unless you are a historic genius
most people are never going to have a
deep reservoir of knowledge on every
subject the most you can hope for to be
a really competent interesting
interested successful knowledgeable
smart person from foremost people like
that you have it you have that deep base
of knowledge on a few subjects but the
school's not interested in that
you know they're not trying to create
people like that instead the school says
no you can't spend too much time on
those subjects that you care about and
that you're good at because we need you
to take Spanish for some reason and
trigonometry and you need a credit in
some kind of art class and you need to
take physical education for one year for
some reason and oh yeah we need you to
take something like aquatic science too
you know because why not and and oh you
have to keep advancing into more and
more advanced math classes and science
classes even if you have not mastered
the first level we're going to push you
on anyway
[Music]
but the problem
there's there there's no point in in
knowing just a little bit of Spanish or
a little bit of calculus or a little bit
of aquatic science it's great to know a
lot about those subjects if you're if
you're bilingual great that's a great
advantage to have if you're a if you are
if you know calculus backwards and
forwards and you really know math and
you're a math math expert great there's
a lot you can do with that there's and
it's it's not just do with it but that
that will make you a more knowledgeable
intelligent person so that's all
fantastic but you can't do anything with
a little on those subjects so it's
something like a foreign language there
is no point in forcing a kid starting in
ninth grade from like 9th to 11th grade
to take a couple of Spanish classes for
45 minutes so you know every few days
for you know it's like there's no point
in that isn't you're not gonna learn the
language that way you're not gonna
really learn anything the most you could
hope is that at the end of that they're
gonna know how to say a couple of
sentences they can ask for the bathroom
name the colors you know and that's the
most they'll know but that's nothing
that's not even hardly the beginning of
something
there's no point with those kinds of
subjects either you've got to really
know them or you might as well not know
them here's so I graduated high school
and I had I had that that very shallow
bit of knowledge on all these different
areas but what happens with shallow
water it evaporates and so that's what
happened with me a lot of my knowledge
whatever a little bit of knowledge I was
forced into my head on on advanced math
concepts and foreign languages and
aquatic science whatever a little bit of
knowledge was all of that evaporated it
was it was already useless I couldn't
done anything with but then within a
couple of years was completely gone
because I didn't care about it I didn't
try to build on it I didn't want to I
knew I didn't want to and so it just
went away what was the point there was
no point it was a toad
waste of time but you know what there is
a point in knowing just a little bit
about the mechanics of a car there is a
point in knowing just a little bit about
like budgeting and things like that
because even if you never expand on that
base of knowledge even the bit you know
will be useful too if the only thing you
know about a car is you can name a
couple other you can point to a couple
of the parts of the engine you can
change the oil check the fluids change
the tire maybe you know when you hear
the clanging of the engine you can kind
of figure out it might be this or that
like if that's all you know about cars
that's that that's not enough to get a
job as a car mechanic but that's enough
that's gonna be very useful to you so if
the schools are gonna force kids to
develop a little bit of knowledge in
certain areas why not those areas why
not force every kid to take a cup to
take at least a class on about cars we
all drive cars that that's actually
useful knowledge that kids could use
even if they never master it but the
school say no well we don't have time
for what enough time for that because we
need you taking calculus when you're in
11th grade even if you're even if you'll
never touch math ever again when you
graduate I know people say what do you
mean you use algebra so daily you can
use algebra everyday no you don't I have
lived
you know I'd like to say pretty
competently and successfully as an adult
for many years now I have never really
used algebra ever never used it
what ever a little bit of math I need to
do I just pull out my phone do it on the
calculator that's that's the modern
world for you I have no need for it so
it's just it doesn't make any sense
the subjects where a little bit of
knowledge would be useful those are
precisely the subjects where kids are
given no knowledge and the subjects
where there's no point to those subjects
unless you're gonna master it kids are
forced to develop a little bit of
knowledge it's just a total waste of
time
so it's no surprise that young people
have little knowledge and little in the
way of interest in ambition because
these things have not been fostered they
have in fact been stifled purpose
we by the school system the school
system wants broad shallow docile people
and it will resort to pretty much any
measure to create those kinds of people
and so that's how you end up with my
generation or at least that's that's
maybe not the whole story that's a big
part of the story what can we do about
it what can we do differently well I
think for the education system for the
education system to really function
properly and to really creates
knowledgeable intelligent competent
people I think for that to have an edge
there would need to be a total overhaul
of the education system the other the
education system needs to be rebuilt
from the ground up I think it's just
completely wrong and how it goes about
almost everything but that's not gonna
happen anytime soon it might never
happen which means that most of us what
needs to happen instead is that once we
get out of the system and we are young
adults that's when the real work begins
of actually learning and growing and
developing skills developing knowledge
I've said before it I really believe it
to be the case that almost everything I
know now I learned after I graduated
almost everything and so that's the work
that we need to do all right we'll leave
it there thanks for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed